we are different one of the nation's I
know professors who drive some crazy to
say American exceptionalism they hate
that the average length of a
constitution in the history of the world
is 17 years this year we're 232 years
under the same Constitution so we are
unique we're the exception not the rule
[Music]
hello and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special I'm excited
to welcome today david barton from wall
builders they focus on America's
forgotten history and heroes they
emphasize the religious moral and
constitutional heritage of our nation
I'm gonna get to all of it in just one
second but first there's a widely held
belief that procrastination is a bad
thing because most of the time it is but
life isn't so black and white sometimes
procrastination can actually work in
your favor for example let's say you
need life insurance but you've been
putting it off because you were lazy
well congratulations you've managed to
procrastinate long enough for technology
to make it really easy for you to get
life insurance policy genius is the easy
way to shop for insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
top insurers and find your best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape no sales pressure no hidden
fees just financial protection and peace
of mind and policy genius doesn't just
make life insurance easy they can also
help you find the right home insurance
auto insurance disability insurance so
if you need life insurance but you've
been busy doing literally anything else
check out policy genius it's the easy
way to compare all the top insurers and
find the best value for you policy
genius com nobody wants to shop for life
insurance which is why they made it easy
for you be a responsible adult make sure
you're not buried in a pauper's grave
and that if something bad should happen
to you your family is taken care of it's
part of being responsible go check them
out at policy genius com that's policy
genius.com david thanks so much for
joining the show really appreciate it
great to be here Brent thanks for having
me so for those who don't know my you
explain what wall builders is wall
builders is his name we take from the
Bible book of Nehemiah we like that
story in the Bible it is the story of
rebuilding that which has been torn down
Nehemiah goes back and it's the largest
grassroots story in the Bible and a
project they thought would be impossible
to achieve they did in 52 days because
everybody did something I like the image
that in rebuilding the walls while you
would normally want stonemasons you had
a guy and his daughters out there you
had apothecaries you had jewelers you
had soldiers everybody did
something and so we look at America and
say you know if everybody gets involved
and does something if they'll just
rebuild as the priest did in Nehemiah
they only rebuilt our own home the
minutes of coal built a long section but
the priest just a little bit okay if
everybody does something the whole thing
goes back up in a remarkably short
period of time so that's the image we
like is wall builders everybody doing
something you don't have to be qualified
or you don't have to be a specialist
just get involved and rebuild something
that's been torn down the morals the
faith the character education politics
whatever it is get in there and rebuild
well I want to get your take on
educational policy in the United States
how that ought to change but I want to
start with you brought some memorabilia
with you so wall builders is an
organization that has one of the largest
private collections founding your
memorabilia documents and and other
materials in in the world
so before we get to you showing me some
of the stuff that's really really cool
you're showing some of this to me before
we actually began filming this how did
you get into actually collecting all of
this stuff I got to go back in my story
I was a math and science guy went to
college from a math and science
scholarship became a teacher and then
became a school principal and math and
science was my deal I did basketball and
coaching other things but I wasn't at
all a history guy didn't like history
didn't like in high school didn't like
in college didn't like it any time and
yet not liking history I came across two
really old documents that I had been
taught about in school and I'd been
taught about those documents but when I
actually read them they were totally
opposite to what I've been taught about
in school and so I'm now I'm going to
wait a minute
here's what I learned but I'm holding
the actuals and they're not the same and
that got me looking at others and the
more I looked in the history the more it
was so different from what I've been
taught and I really loved what I was
finding and so at that point I did lots
of public speaking and we actually
retired six vans at 300,000 miles on
each van we just drove all over the
United States so many times millions of
miles and as we would go through places
we would stop in towns at a thrift shop
or Salvation Army or you know something
I remember walking into a store in
Connecticut where that as I walked out I
had the
to use dresses to go by and never use
stoves over here and tricycles go over
here and in the back I found a box of
leather-bound books and it turned out to
be the library of one of the founding
fathers and people had had his books and
their selling of five books a book they
didn't have a clue with the head and so
as I have and I would say when I started
I could out of 250 founding fathers
maybe named five so I didn't know who
must have more so I ended up buying a
book from a guy named Hugh Williamson
for 12 bucks well he's one of the 39
guys who signed the Constitution but
nobody's ever heard of them today so at
that point in time I was able to just
buy lots of stuff and read it and give
it through all their writings just this
is amazing it's not what I was taught
now today it's a little different
because with internet you can google and
say oh this guy was a signer of the
Constitution I'll raise the price on him
but back then it was really easy to get
this stuff so today now there's probably
80 or 90 vendors who make a living
selling the stuff they know that we buy
and so they'll contact us and say do you
want this and so now I don't have to go
out and search like we did before but it
was a really fun journey finding all
this old stuff I mean you brought some
of it with you and I want to give you
the opportunity to kind of show our
listeners and our viewers what exactly
you have because some of this stuff is
just unbelievable you're showing it to
me before the show so well we'll start
with George Washington an easy name to
recognize this actually are two parts of
one lock of his hair he gave this lock
to Alexander Hamilton as as he was dying
at at Mount Vernon and so the Hamilton
family with two kids divided is so this
is what went to the son of Alexander
Hamilton this is a daughter and this
ring is braided hair and there so this
is just an amazing thing to hold the
hair of George Washington back then we
kind of say hair that's kind of creepy
it's back then that was how you passed
yourself on from generation generations
you've passed on a lock of hair and so
that's from from Hamilton one of the
signers of the Declaration 56 signers
and this is kind of an interesting thing
for me now being in history is I'll
speak at law schools and speak of these
really good sharp kids and I can ask
them I'll show them a picture of 56
signers of the Declaration say who can
you recognize up there
and they usually get Jefferson and
Franklin I've only one time ever had
somebody's name a third one and said no
way but there's 56 guys here give me
some more and they never can and so I
find it interesting that basically we've
been trained to recognize the two least
religious guys and we know nothing about
the others and so when you jump into
this guy he's a signer of the
Declaration his name is Francis
Hopkinson he designed the first American
flag George Washington made it one of
our first federal judges but he's a
church music director and choir leader
and this is actually the first purely
American hymn book is the first hymn
book in America to ever have music in it
and what he did was set the hundred and
fifty psalms to music so this the entire
book of psalms set to music his thing
was listening the psalms like david sing
the psalm so this is from a signer of
the declaration you also have items like
this this is a Bible from 1782
this Bible from 1782 is one of the
rarest in the world they printed 10,000
copies back then there's eight copies
left in private hands and this is this
one of them there's a few other copies
and institutions but what makes this
amazing is on the inside of this Bible
and by the way this is the first Bible
printed in English in America it has a
congressional endorsement on the inside
and it says resolve the Congress the
United States recommend this edition
bobbled the habits the United States is
printed by the printer of Congress this
was just plain to Congress that this was
quote a neat addition the Holy
Scriptures for the use of schools and
you going wait a minute I was told the
founding fathers didn't want religion
near school at all and you go well what
do you do with this congressionally
endorsed Bible for the use of schools so
that there's just so many things like
that it's kind of fun to to back up even
the works like this this is a guy named
John wise he's a pastor in Massachusetts
and historians like a Cornel they say
when you look at this sixth greatest
intellectual forces that helps shape
America because we are different one of
the nation's I know professors who drive
some crazy to say American
exceptionalism they hate that the
average length of a constitution in the
history of the world is 17 years this
year we're 232 years under the same
Constitution so we are unique where the
exception not the rule but when you take
and look at where the ideas come came
from professor said John wise was one of
the six most influential writers on the
founding fathers thinking and it was
this book the Sons of Liberty reprint
now this originally came out in 1710 and
1717 Sons of Liberty reprinted this in
1772 so this is edition from the Sons of
Liberty and it has two long sermons in
here that he did and from these sermons
we get the phrase that all men are
created equal we get the concept they're
endowed by the creator of certain enable
rights he talks about how that taxation
without representation is tyranny he
talks about how that all the forms of
government the Bible God's preferred
form is the consent of the governed all
of these phrases end up in the
declaration came out of his writings his
sermons and so those are the kind of
things we have and you know I were
talking earlier and this is a guy I
really like John Locke
the two treatises of government Richard
Henry Lee signed the Declaration said
that they quote copied the declaration
out of this book and so as you go
through this book it's fun to read I
mean that little just the the out
politics for government are amazing but
he cites the Bible references the Bible
more than 1500 times and this and this
is what the founders used to create this
successful document so that's that's the
kind of stuff we have we got so much
more I've got John Hancock stuff and so
many other founding fathers but we just
have a blast learning this stuff because
it's not what we were taught in school
and then sharing it with others well one
of the things they've been talking about
a lot and is really important to me I
mean I brought a book that largely
concerns this is the impact of religious
thought on American Founding thought so
obviously you've you've mentioned it a
couple of times you should hone in on it
there's this idea that's taught in
schools that effectively America is a
secular country that it was founded
along the idea of separation of church
and state and to this end the First
Amendment is is often cited the idea
that you can't establish a religion and
then forgetting about the second half
which is that there's freedom of
religion so what exactly in your view
was the relationship of founding thought
to religion how much did the founders
rely on religious thought and what did
they think in terms of governance and
religion how this you should be balanced
they were very adamant that you do not
separate religious principle
now doctrines are one thing religious
principles or something else and so when
they said there should be no
establishment religion back then an
establishment of religion was a state
established religion they had no trouble
with religion they promoted it the first
federal law that was passed dealing with
how you become a territory in the United
States is called the Northwest Ordinance
George Washington signed that own own
August the 7th of 1789
that's how 32 States became States in
the United States and that law
specifically says article 3 religion
morality and knowledge being necessary
to good government and the happiness of
mankind schools and means of Education
shall forever be encouraged so to this
day if you look in constitutions like
the current North Carolina Constitution
you look in Iowa or Kansas etcetera it
says forever in the public schools of
the state religion and morality would be
taught as well as knowledge so they saw
that as a mandate that you can't be part
of America if your schools don't promote
religion morality now which particular
denomination no we're not doing that but
the principles of Bible principles of
how we control ourselves behave behavior
our morality it all comes from there and
so they were huge into promoting that I
mentioned that there were two documents
that just kind of turned me around one
of them was I actually got a copy of
George Washington's 1796 farewell
address and that's considered one of the
most significant presidential speeches
ever given it's interesting that we have
state laws from 1820 more than 1820 you
were required in States to take a
written exam on four documents every
year for the first eight years of school
and those four documents were the US
Constitution the Declaration of
Independence the state constitution and
George Washington's farewell address you
had to study that you had to know that a
written exam for the first eight years
of school once a year it's interesting
that in the Civil War Abraham Lincoln
actually issued a general order to all
the Union troops who said guys if you're
not fighting the enemy today I want you
to spend the whole day reading George
Washington's farewell address meditating
on his principles thinking about what he
said same happened in World War one with
Woodrow Wilson read
farewell address so we really thought
this was significant and in the farewell
address Washington is saying okay here
we are at two terms
I'm leaving retiring you all know what
we've been through and he talks about
economics he talks about what happened
to revolution and he says and now my
fellow citizens as I leave here's a few
thoughts and they're almost like
warnings I mean one of the things he
says is don't let the federal government
get into deficit spending now it's one
of his great warnings he talks about
avoiding foreign entanglements a you
know try to keep sovereignty here and
don't get tied in Foreign Wars and so
all this why stuff but what he says he
says of all the habits and dispositions
that lead to political prosperity
religion and morality are indispensable
supports he said in vain would that man
claim the tribute of patriotism
who should labor this from birth these
great pillars so he goes out saying guys
anybody that tries to separate religion
and morality from public life from
politics they're not Patriots they're
trying to destroy the nation and that's
a big litmus test and I was told that
Washington was a great deist that he was
not a faith guy and here he's saying
guys don't if anybody tries to take
faith out of the public square they're
not a patriot I'm going oh my gosh
that's not what I was taught and so when
I read his farewell address it really
got me thinking what else did I think
get taught right and so separation of
church and States one of those phrase is
that the way we use it today probably
the best way to explain it
the phrase did not originate with
Jefferson it originated back in the 14
and 1500s John Greenwood a pastor and
Great Britain's probably the first guy
that credited with saying it back in the
1500s and so they wrote about it for
hundreds of years before Jefferson
picked it up so he was repeating what
historical writers had said but even in
Jefferson's letter which he wrote on
January the 1st 1802 that's the famous
letter the courts quote today on
separation of church and state that
letter is 233 words long it's three
paragraphs it's easy to put in a
footnote in any court case and since
1947 no quote no court has quoted more
than 8 words
a wall of separation between church and
state that's it every court that used it
before 47 quoted the whole letter like
Reynolds versus United States since 1878
and every time they quoted the whole
letter of Jefferson they said look based
on what Jefferson said separation church
and state means you can't stop a public
religious activity and so we always kept
religion in public life using the
separation phrase until a case in 47
called Everson versus Board of Education
and the court said oh look what
Jefferson said separation we can't have
any religion life no read the whole
there's a reason they don't put the
whole letter in there when you read the
whole letter you it's obvious what
Jefferson said because you had a group
in Connecticut saying we're afraid the
government's going to shut down our
religious activities expression
he said no there's a wall of separation
between church and state they will not
stop your religious activities that's
not what we get today so that's the kind
of stuff that really started turning me
over and saying I wasn't taught this I
got a whole different line even
separation church and state and so if
you go back and look at what Jefferson
did oh my gosh
Jefferson started Church in the US
Capitol building every week we had
Church in the capitol by 1857 the
largest Church Protestant Church the
United States met in the Capitol every
week
Jefferson started that he invited
preachers to preach at that church how
is that separation well that's why we
don't look at what he actually did or
said we just use a phrase from them so
in a second I ask you about the
religious viewpoints of the founders
because those are often misconstrued or
misunderstood but first with the ever
increasing numbers of car makes and
models it's now impossible to stock all
the parts you need in a traditional
chain storefront
why endure the often pointless and
seemingly intimidating questioning like
is your Odyssey and LX or Annie X and
then wait while the counter man orders
the only parts on his computer just
happening to choose the only brand his
warehouse happens to carry well you also
have a computer with access to the
Internet which is a really cool place
and that has access to Rock Auto comm at
home and in your pocket Rock auto comm
is a family business they've served Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years go
to rock Auto comm and shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake
parts two tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
daily driver get everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle choose the
brands specifications and prices you
prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers why spend up to twice
as much for the same parts they've got
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
Rock Auto calm go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck right shapiro in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
we sent you okay so let's talk about the
religious perspective of the founders so
the the typical narrative goes in public
education i was in public school and i
went to public school for college as
well the typical historians tend to say
that the founders were basically diaz
that they believed in the clockwork
universe maker he set the universe in
motion and then through natural law
discoveries we came up with all of these
wonderful ideas but the bible is really
sort of a secondary afterthought that
these were all dias there may have been
sort of a root-level
theists belief system that they believed
in but but when it came to the bible
they didn't take it literally they
didn't take it seriously what do you
make of that characterization of the
founders characterizations the right
word and it's based on the fact that we
really don't know them or who they are
we actually reprinted an old 1848 public
school textbook that we used for
generations in public schools we studied
all 56 signers of the Declaration we
knew who they were their names their
character their sacrifices we knew their
faith their family when you all about
them today we know a small handful
I was recently with an academic at Notre
Dame and he jumped me and said you
overstate the faith that the founding
fathers they were largely deist I said
okay here's the deal
you name it a deal what you call it you
name what you call it Dias founding
father and for everyone you name I'll
name five overt ones that today would
probably be considered evangelicals and
religious terms so you name one I'll
name five let's see who runs out first
well he got through three or four and
kind of ran out I'm still going over
here on the other side and the problem
is we take the the least and we make
that in
to the rule and the rule is that for
example the 56 signers of the
Declaration 29 of them graduated from
schools that in their day were
considered Bible schools or seminaries
now you can have a hard time convincing
me that Adeus is going to attend a Bible
School or a Seminary a place that
trained ministers you know and they were
largely Christians so that's their faith
we see it in evidence and their writings
which I would collect so much you know
just and an easy one is to take somebody
like a John Hancock this is an original
proclamation from John Hancock and this
is for the state of Massachusetts and by
the way he's calling them to a day of
public fasting humiliation and prayer
which is fairly serious that's kind of
serious on your faith but you find
throughout that he is very open as a
Christian he he caught talks about Jesus
Christ and Savior etc 22 times he called
the state of Massachusetts of Prayer
like this you find that by the time you
get to 1815 there had been 1400
government issued calls to prayer in
America largely by founding fathers so
if they're deist why did they have you
praying
and why they calling you to prayer with
what might be considered evangelical
language there's he would alternate
oftentimes with Thanksgiving and fasting
this is one of Hancock's Thanksgiving
proclamations this is when we found out
Benedict Arnold was trying to kill
George Washington and it's a Saxon
amazing story and he says Wow the the
fingerprints of God and this are such to
know that this was a god thing because
the way the weight came out they should
never discover the trees and it should
never been discovered was too well-laid
plan so people don't know that story
maybe you can tell the story yeah that
this story is really kind of interesting
because Benedict Arnold had an ego and
his ego didn't get matched in the
American army because he thought he
should've been promoted much faster and
he wasn't being recognized and wasn't
being promoted so he starts saying well
the British will respect me they'll
honor me I can get a promotion through
them and so he starts working with the
British he's in charge of West Point by
the way the biggest statute you find
when you go to the battlefield at
Saratoga which is the first major
American Revolution massive statue of
Benedict Donald because he was the hero
he was a American general he was
courageous but he just didn't think he
got enough respect and so because of
that ego kind of thing he turns the
British and so he works with them and
because his American general is so good
he has West Point all of West Point is
under his control and so he makes this
plan to give West Point to the British
and he's going to happen there at the
time the George Washington arrives so
they can kill Washington or capture
Washington in everything right there so
what happens is a British officer Andre
John Andre is going back and forth with
Benedict Arnold and so they make the
plans they lay it out
Andreea actually takes the plans Folsom
up puts him in the bottom his shoe to
hide in case anybody stops and they
won't find it and he gets into what is
considered to be a safe part of New York
it just run by the British all the
loyalists are there he's out of the
American part of New York he's back in
the British part of New York and he runs
up on three guys and starts talking to
them and these guys that they're British
guys I can tell him what's going on it
starts sharing more information than he
should have turned out they weren't
British guys there were three American
militiamen who had just escaped from a
British prison and so here's three
Americans who shouldn't even be in this
area they were prisoners they got free
and now as Arnold starts becoming a
little too open with them they started
getting a little curious and they
started thinking this doesn't smell
right and so they actually grab him and
take him to an American post which
wasn't supposed to be in that area at
all so everything was improbable all the
way through they searched didn't find
anything and they said I searched again
and for some reason check the bottom of
his shoe found the papers so it's just
everything was it was just too many
coincidence is that what they saw this
this is too providential to too much God
here and so that's why Hancock called
for that that time of Thanksgiving and
it's interesting another part of
American history that I think we do a
very poor job with today is when you
look at American history is largely
white and Protestant for example we
never talk about the Jewish founding
fathers were particularly about Jewish
qualms
raishin back then the fact that John at
present John Adams president and John
Quincy Adams both called for the
reestablishment of Israel as an
independent nation back in that day I
mean nobody knows that and then you
start talking about what the founding
women did and how that wives like friend
Elizabeth Lewis the the wife of Francis
that were signed at the Declaration was
a prisoner of war for what she did for
the Revolution actually died as a result
and so there were three women who were
persons away I mean just what the women
did is unbelievable and then you throw
in for example what what blacks did in
the revolution we think of the
Revolution as a bunch of white guys know
there were so many black founding
fathers if I can call them that and one
of the best stories deals with Benedict
Arnold
because Benedict Arnold once they
discovered the treason he jumps over to
the British side quick to get out of
town before he gets executed for treason
and so he's now British side they make
him eat general and so as the the
British Army is moving south out of New
York down towards Yorktown Pennock
Donald big part of that he he took his
soldiers he raided New London
Connecticut the the battle Groton
Heights was Bennett Donald killing
Americans and so you get that he's now
British general and as they work down
into Virginia one of the problems George
Washington has in young general
Lafayette is they just don't have any
intelligence on what the British are
doing they don't know what the British
do until they see it it's like if we
could know we could plan we could be
prepared and so a black man named james
Armistead became good friends with
Lafayette he was fighting in the
revolution and Lafayette white guy in
Lafayette was massive anti-slavery guy
and so big equality guy and as she's
talking it's kind of like in the
conversation it kind of goes that
Lafayette says man if we could just have
some intelligence know what they were
doing it so help us and and James said
well I'm I'm willing to go do that and
and lock it no no that that's way too
dangerous you and so there's talking and
and James says no I'll do that and so
what happens is James go straggling into
the British camp and he goes straggling
in
he says I'm an escaped slave I hate the
Americans they're so mean to me they're
just and and so the British said well
we'll take you in and so he begins
faithfully serving the British and
fairly soon they say hey why don't we
let you serve the officers because
you're really good great attitude just
know we love you so they made him the
servant to Benedict Arnold the British
general so here you got a spy now who's
with Bennet Arnold and Arnold is with
all the other British generals as
they're making their plans and so what
happens is james Armistead every night
gets word back to life yet in Washington
here's what they're doing and so the
British are moving around and suddenly
the Americans aren't where they're
supposed to be and they're over here
with the British are and then they send
Benedict Arnold off on a mission so he's
gone so James stays behind the British
camp and Lord Cornwallis actually takes
him on as his servant so now you got the
commander-in-chief with the spy there
and they're having a conversation kind
of thing and it's like Cornwallis says
man we've got to have a spy in the camp
somewhere because now the Americans know
what we're doing before we do it and
James I know it's gonna be really hard
but you've been so good to us I know
you're gonna hate this idea but would
you go back and be a spy for us against
the Americans and say oh no don't make
me go back to America see he becomes the
first double spy in American history and
because of his intelligence is why we're
able to trap Cornwallis out in Yorktown
in the American Revolution so Washington
and Lafayette other guys credit a black
double spy first double spy on American
history with bringing the revolution to
an early end saving countless lives
who's ever heard of james Armistead now
who's ever heard of a guy like you have
a guy Prince Sisson one of the first
SEAL team members ever black guy what a
remarkable mission they had in Newport
and capturing a British general and just
it's the stuff of Hollywood movies and
there's so many black folks most people
in Indiana have no idea that they're
named the Hoosier State
named after a black preacher named Harry
Hoosier who converted so many people
that moved into Indiana that was known
as the Hoosier State after a black guy
in the American Founding so you have all
these black soldiers we don't nothing
about what we do today is we show the
bad
the ugly about America but not much of
the good and so if we can show slavery
which is the southern view we'll do that
but we're not going to point out that
there was never time in Massachusetts
when blacks could not vote that we had
blacks elected office in America in 1768
when we're Chas well re-elected for 49
years old eight different political
positions he was kind of like the black
Paul Revere Road New England warning
people about the British coming
we don't hear these guys and so that's
one of the things that I think we really
do wrong on history today is we know so
little about it and we characterize so
much and the characterization is not
accurate all this goes back to your
simple question of the faith of the
founders we characterize them as deist
well we choose two or three or four and
even they're not deist I mean you can
choose Franklin Franklin early in his
riding said I'm a deist but then George
Whitefield comes to America he gets
involved with George Whitefield actually
builds a place on his ass for whitfill
to stay and after whitfill spend there
Franklin's life goes in a different
direction and he has such a faith guy
for the rest of his life but people
point to that one letter he wrote when
he was 20-something where he called
himself a deist and they don't look at
the change that happened in his later
life so even the guys would call this
George Washington I mean the guys who
knew him best
Jared sparks did the first edition
Washington's writings he actually
interviewed all the people who were with
Washington a lot of people I can't say
all but key people he even there in
viewed his own family and they said you
might as well question Washington's
patron system this question his
Christianity I mean everybody in the day
said no way is he a deist so we've got
his records we've got his writings but
today we call him a deist and it just
doesn't line up historically and that's
that's why we like original documents
and going back and by the way Ben I got
to say I so appreciate you for your
faith your stand for faith I appreciate
you for your love for truth do you keep
going back to truth and you don't care
for defense both sides or either side
and your courage and doing that and that
love of truth I mean when you get back
to the actual documents you get such a
different narrative of America than what
we see today so I won't ask you about
one specific founding father and though
the one that people always cite is that
the key deist
Jefferson who writes the Jefferson Bible
goes through
all of the sections that he finds
troublesome particularly sections
relating to miracles how should we view
Jefferson's faith because people because
he wrote the Declaration of Independence
and obviously becomes president and the
Declaration of Independence is seen as
in in many ways even more foundational
to the to the country than the
Constitution Lincoln obviously thought
that you could only read the two in
tandem and it was for that reason that
the Civil War was worthwhile and moral
so looking at Jefferson's faith how
should we adjudicate where Jefferson was
in terms of his belief in God was he
just a peer deist no that not at all as
a matter of fact and let me let me hit
real quick on what you said declaration
and Constitution you cannot separate the
two the founding father said you
couldn't they specifically said that and
the US Code Annotated today the two
documents you cannot violate with any
law or the Declaration and the
Constitution so modern stuff we
separated that because the Declaration
has so much faith in it the Constitution
doesn't a constitution has a lot of
faith that I could easily point that out
but people think it doesn't so in their
minds they separate the religious from
the secular and it is striking that the
Constitution article seven dates itself
to the declaration it goes every federal
law sign president Trump what he saw in
last week doesn't go to the Constitution
goes to the declaration so we've never
separated those two till modern culture
wanted kind of secular eyes it going
back to Jefferson when people asked me
about the Jefferson Bible that question
you know I get well he cut out all the
things he disagreed with and and then I
started asking them questions I said
okay
which Jefferson Bible are you talking
about when you meet the Jefferson Bible
yeah which one you talking about the
1804 the 1821 there were two yeah well
if they don't know there's two I don't I
know they don't know what they're
talking about then I asked well have you
ever read either one of them well no
well then how do you know he cut out the
miraculous supernatural what everybody
says right so go back and read it so if
we go back to the 1804 version he's in
the white house he's president he takes
two Bibles he cuts out sections in the
Bible paste them all together now that's
the first Jefferson Bible and he did
that largely he had been given a friend
piece a guy named piece gave him a
sermon from a guy in Scotland named Ben
and the guy in Scotland said look if you
want to reach America Native Americans
with Christianity do not give them a
Bible because if you do they might read
the genealogies they might read you know
and then that's not what you want he
said what you need to do is take the
teachings of Jesus and give them the
teachings of Jesus don't give him the
whole Bible and Jefferson great idea so
what Jefferson cut out was what in
Christian terms would be called the red
letters of the Bible so cut out the
words of Jesus pasted them all and in if
you read that you find Jesus healing the
sick and raising the dead and casting
out Devils and all the miracles that are
there it's there and so okay what
happened to all the supernatural stuff
that you said he cut out because it's
there and and by the way he did that he
gave that to some missionary friends he
was really close to the Native Americans
he was really into wanting to share the
Bible with them and so he gave that to
some missionary friends and this is much
cheaper to print than the whole Bible
these are the teachings of Jesus and
instead of going through four teachings
and four Gospels it's got the teaching
one time so you don't read it four times
so it's what's often called a synoptic
Bible it's just a linear Bible and the
teachings you so it has supernatural
stuff all throughout so I say well
obviously he couldn't been speaking
about the 18:04 Bible you must been
speaking about the 1820 Bible if you
ever read that no oh okay let's talk
about that because on all this that I'm
telling you this is all recorded in
Jefferson's writings these are in his
writings people look at the product they
don't read what he said or why he did it
or anything else they they just jumped
to this characterization again so the
1821 Jefferson starts writing so many of
his friends he said the thing that helps
you have limited government is having
moral people and when you have more
people you have less need for outside
government because you have more
internal government so he started
reading the writings of every moral
philosopher he could find he I mean
Pythagoras and Cato and played on all
the guys and he told friend after friend
he said I've read them all and I think
the moral teachings of Jesus are better
than any of those teachings and so what
he did in his
own handwriting he went through and
picked 81 to what he considered the best
moral teachings of Jesus and he then
pasted them in to end in a day book that
he had but because he spoke several
languages he also pasted the same
teachings into end in Latin and in Greek
and in French and so he would read all
all the teachings Jesus four languages
and so that's what he read on a daily
basis nobody really knew he had that
book until the librarian of Congress
Cyrus Adler and 1886 was talking to a
grandson of Jefferson and the grandson
do you i-i've got his book on all the
MOL teaches of Jesus and this is
brilliant would like to buy this so
Library of Congress bought it then in
1902 a congressman John Lacey out of
Iowa read this and said this is the
greatest collection of moral teachings
we've ever seen so he started writing
op-eds about Jefferson's Jefferson
Bibles what it became known as and so he
wrote op eds
and in 1904 Congress took it and
reprinted it and gave a copy to every
member of Congress for the next 50 years
and said if you will live by the moral
teachings here you won't have ethical
problems you won't have corruption etc
and so it's that's what's called the
Jefferson Bible today Jefferson's own
handwriting because the book is a
reproduction of Jefferson's own notes
it's called the life and morals of Jesus
with Nazareth and so it has the great
command love God with all your heart
with all your soul with all your mind
forgiving your enemies kindness to
enemies it's got 81 moral teachings and
that's the Jefferson Bible and they say
oh it doesn't have any any supernatural
stuff in it it does but that wasn't his
purpose his purpose was collecting moral
teachings so if you're telling me that
Jefferson so hated the Bible that he
eliminated supernatural than first you
got explained with 1804 is all about
second I'll show you all sorts of
supernatural stuff because there's
heaven and hell and angels all sorts of
stuff and the moral teachings of Jesus
so both of them have supernatural but
then I've got to ask you to explain to
me why it is that Jefferson was a
lifetime member of the Virginia Bible
Society if he's so hated Bibles
was a lifetime member and if he so hated
Bibles why was one of the three largest
contributions he ever gave was to a
Bible Society to help spread Bibles and
why is it that he gave a full Bible to
every one of his kids and grandkids when
they learned to read that was the first
reading book he wanted them to have was
a full Bible so I asked people say if
Jefferson so hates the Bible then how do
you explain all this behavior and the
problem is since about 1903 what's known
as the Unitarians have said Jefferson's
Unitarian and he didn't like Jesus and
so and they've adopted him but
academically you can't sustain that
position and so when you look at truth
and read Jefferson's writings when you
actually read both of the books the
Jefferson Bible you come up with a
completely different conclusion than
what academic you know how this with
academics they repeat each other they
don't go back to original sources they
quote each other and so that's how the
Jefferson's gotten a bad rap as is asked
to his faith he kept calling himself a
Christian now as a Christian I would say
probably not Orthodox in some visibly
but he caught he certainly didn't run
from that title I would say from my
standpoint he's probably not a Christian
but that's not my decision that's God's
decision you know that's if he if he had
here did that faith he wasn't an enemy
of it by any means he was an enemy of
some of its doctrines but never of Jesus
and never of the Scriptures just some
parts of it so that's that's kind of
really if I can say it that kind of the
truth behind the Jefferson Bible that we
just rarely get today so one of the
things that I want to ask you about is
what the role of the state was in
promoting religion huh early on because
obviously this has become a very
controversial proposition when asked
about that in just a second but first
you get to the end of the day and you
were trying to go to sleep and you find
it really difficult you're struggling to
say but you're not alone one in three US
adults doesn't get enough sleep I am one
of these people if you're not sleeping
enough it can affect your cognitive
functions during the day like learning
problem solving decision making that's
why we're partnering with comb the
number one app for sleep sleep
deficiency does serious damage not just
your brain but your body as well the
sleepless are more prone to accidents
weight gain depression with calm you'll
discover a whole library of programs
designed to help you get to sleep
your brain and body need like
soundscapes and over a hundred sleep
stories narrated by soothing voices like
to roam Flynn from Game of Thrones and
Stephen Fry so if you want to seize the
day sleep tonight with the help of comb
right now my listeners ben shapiro
listeners get 25% off a calm premium
subscription at comb calm slash been at
sea alm calm slash men forty million
people have downloaded calm find out why
at calm calm slash man by the way it
doesn't just work on adults it also
works on children they've got these
sleep stories puts your kids right out
go check them out right now at calm calm
slash been at sea alm calm slash been
okay so let's talk about there's kind of
a rich debate that's broken out in
modern times right now and it has a lot
of historical antecedents obviously and
that is what is the role of government
in promoting or or not promoting
religious institutions so this this
debate is I think quite fascinating
because it pits a lot of conservatives
against each other you have folks who
consider themselves classically liberal
I put myself more in this category where
I say that the the entire bargain of the
government was that the government was
basically going to stay out of this
realm specifically because they assumed
there would be immoral and religious
people that was going to fill that gap
and then there a group of folks who said
the government should take a more
forcible position in trying to promote
religious morality judeo-christian
morality what's your view of where the
founders came down on that the founders
came down on is being part of the
culture of the side not the doctrine
society but the culture society you
wanted a biblically moral you one of the
biblical morals of culture there were a
lot of malls available time I mean we
had a 32-year war where we fought Muslim
morals and it it was because we did not
agree with their morals we ended the
American Revolution in 1783 really the
first foreign group for ambassadors that
Congress sends out its in 1784 and as
Thomas Jefferson John Adams and has been
Franklin and as go negotiate with the
Muslims that keep attacking us and so we
end up with a 32-year war against
against Islamic terrorists part of that
is when the first Quran is printed in
America and that was done by Isaiah
Thomas which is kind of like the Simon &
Schuster of their day and they printed
it's that you guys need to read what's
in here because when you read what's in
the Quran you'll understand
and why this is so incompatible with the
morals and the values we've but they
think you go to heaven for killing
people my gosh what kind of morals as
that and that's actually what Jefferson
wrote in a letter to the State
Department in 1786 he said we finally
asked us this Muslim bastard we've done
nothing to you this Muslim why do you
keep attacking us why do you keep
hitting our ships and killing our guys
and enslaving and he said because that's
how we go to heaven and Jefferson's like
no way and so that's when Jefferson went
and bought a Quran for the first time in
read it two volumes said he got in
London 1764 edition read it and that
helped him then know how to fight them
in subsequent years when he sent the
Army Navy to Tripoli from the halls of
Montezuma shores of Tripoli at the
Marine Corps hymn so there were there
were malls that were incompatible what
we believed were constitutional freedoms
sharia law would be within that because
they don't allow religious freedom so we
believed that the government needed to
promote those things that it wanted to
preserve and if you want to preserve
freedom you got to promote the things
that that enhance freedom because if you
have a people that don't believe those
those beliefs then you can't survive as
the nation which is kind of where we are
now we're so polarized everybody's got
their own value system and you can't be
cohesive as a nation so within that
framework they promoted what we would
call biblical values of morality
now I'll point out that you take
somebody like Ben Franklin I don't think
he was a Christian but I will also point
out that he was very close friends with
Thomas Paine Thomas Paine probably is
the least religious of the founding
fathers so but even at that pain is not
anti root he's not anti religious in the
ways presented today we actually have a
six-page letter from Thomas Paine were
that he is defending himself from the
attacks made on him by other founding
fathers because in 1793 he came out with
the age of reason and the age of reason
attacked Judaism and attack Christianity
attacked Old Testament New Testament
went after all of it but it was Pro God
and so when the founding father saw that
they attacked him Patrick Henry wrote a
whole book against him you had Sam Adams
doing op eds on him and in Boston
newspapers
you had George Washington and never
spoke to him again I mean the guys just
turned their back you're gonna be
anti-religious you're not the guy we
thought you were and so in that period
of time before he brought the age of
reason he actually took the manuscript
ideas and sent him all to Ben Franklin
and said hey look over this tell me what
you think and so it's an attempt to
remove religion from America and
Franklin wrote him back and said this is
a terrible idea
he said I would advise you to burn this
paper but before de'cine by any other
person and he talked about what it would
be to unchained the tiger and and if you
take the biblical morals out of american
do you realize what you're doing and so
he said think how great a portion of
mankind have needed the motives of
religion to restrain their vice to
support their virtue and so Franklin
advised him not to he went ahead and did
it and suffered the tax he had but when
Sam Adams wrote that piece against pain
and I op-ed in the Boston papers pain
then wrote a six-page letter back to to
Sam Adams and that's the letter we have
he says I am a huge God believer he said
I wrote the age of reason because I saw
France had in a headlong in the atheism
he said atheism will destroy any nation
I'm trying to tell them they need God
and they I don't believe in Christianity
leave in Judaism but you need God and so
even the least religious founding father
Thomas Paine is trying to keep God at
the center of the nation because being
God conscious is a restraint on your
behavior you know scriptures are pretty
clear for faith people that if you stop
thinking about God your behavior changes
really quick and so we do things to help
us remember to think about God the way
we treat one another it's different when
we think about God accounting to him so
that's where the founding fathers were I
mentioned there were two documents that
really kind of flipped me one was
Washington's farewell address where he's
clearly saying if you want political
prosperity don't secularize the country
don't secularize the nation don't take
religion out the second thing that hit
me was I found in 1844 US Supreme Court
case that was a unanimous decision and
in that case the court no
in my life I've been involved with eight
cases at the US Supreme Court that have
dealt with religious expression some
wave shape fashion form so as I was
reading this 1844 case it was quoting
founding fathers like James Wilson who
was a signer of the Constitution and
Declaration second most active member at
the Constitutional Convention he is the
original justice on the Supreme Court
started the first law school I mean a
big guy and it's quoting all these
founding fathers and I was reading the
case but it said hey if you're going to
be a government funded school in America
you will teach the Bible we're not going
to have a government funded school that
won't teach the Bible because we need
the morals that come from the Bible now
they said you have to teach the Bible
without note or comment you don't go
through an ADD doctrine to it you just
teach the Bible as a book and so that
was the position we took all the way
until 1963 that position changed in 63
were in 62 first in England and 763 and
happiness chant murkrow let the court
said hey we think what we've been doing
for three hundred and forty years is
wrong no more voluntary prayer no more
Bible reading that's all going and it's
significant to me that in those cases
the court said what we're doing is
without historical or legal precedent
it's never before done in American
history so literally in our collection
of stuff we have lots of educational
documents we have a big section on
education textbooks on on whether it's
geography or math or English one of the
text books you find across all
generations is Bible all to win
education till 63 so we taught that we
thought the morals were good you don't
have to be a Christian Jew you don't
have to be a religious person but if you
if you behaved by those morals we have a
self-governing nation less government
needed limited government so that was
really the view they saw they did not
want the government promoting religions
or penalizing and promoting religious
doctrines or penalizing people for not
having the right doctrine but they did
want to promote religion or morality but
not all religion not all morality
biblical morality is what they were
after
and so they did make that distinction
like with Muslims and others all the
Muslims were always welcome to come to
and we never kept but we did say but
realize when you get here the moral
standards we use are these
judeo-christian royal standards so in a
second I want to ask you about that
because there there is a question that
I've been asked as I say in my new book
I write a fair bit about this and one of
the questions that I'm often asked is
well you know it's true that there was a
lot of Christian talk at the time of the
founding it's true that people were
studying the Bible but that's because
you know that's just what everybody did
at the time was this really you know key
to the philosophy of the founding is
there any real connection between the
Bible and the philosophy of the founding
and ask you that question in just one
second first as you know from watching
the news the big tech companies they're
all looking for your data why because
they make gobs and gobs of cash because
you and I aren't giving them all of that
data for free well if you want to keep
giving them your data go right ahead but
you should know that you too can be
earning money off your own data with big
token here's how it works first you
download the app and you sign up for a
free big token account next you complete
actions to earn points actions include
answering surveys checking into
locations connecting your social
accounts and more then you can redeem
those points for awards like cash and
gift cards you can even donate your
earnings to charity if you're that kind
of person you choose what data you share
with big token and then you get paid for
it your data is always secured in big
token the best part you get paid if you
want to start earning money for your
data go to the App Store or Google Play
search for big token that's b.i.g tok en
that's one word download the app sign up
make sure to use my referral code ben
shapiro again search big token in the
App Store or Google Play
download the app use my referral code
ben shapiro to sign up claim your data
get paid there's no reason everybody
else you make money off your data use
your own data and get paid at big token
and use referral code ben shapiro to
sign up already so the question that I
was posing before the break is that you
know when when folks talk about sort of
the connection between founding
philosophy and judeo-christian morality
there's this attempt by some folks to
basically say well sure all these people
read the Bible and sure they refer to
the Bible but about that that's just
because this is what the culture was I
mean what else would they be it wasn't
like there was a thriving atheistic
community in eighteen seventeen sixty in
the same way that there is in say 1960
so is this really more of a it just sort
of happened here and everybody happened
to be Christian and and believed in
judeo-christian values or was there some
deep philosophical connection
between judeo-christian values and the
American Founding I'm going to back into
the answer to that question a couple of
ways one is for all the collection that
we have of founding documents we have
more than a hundred and twenty thousand
originals or copies of original founding
documents from before 1812 so I have so
many of the handwritten documents of
these guys and having read thousands and
thousands and thousands of their letters
and their works etc and having myself
studied the Bible for a long time you
know as a kid I grew up and I believe
that you need to read the Scriptures
kind of like from cover to cover every
year you know you go through it and so
therefore I'm very familiar with
biblical rhetoric and language an aside
read the founders writings I kept seeing
these Bible verses all throughout their
writings and so what happened was a few
years ago a publishing company came to
me and said hey would you would you do a
commentary in the Bible
no you don't need my opinions but I know
somebody who can't comment on the Bible
and so what we did was we took the
letters of the founding fathers and when
they would cite a specific Bible verse
for why they did something we'd let that
be the commentary in that part of the
Bible so the result in what we call the
founders Bible it's them commenting on
the Bible but as an example Jeremiah
17:9 John Adams has three letters sended
the principle in Jeremiah 17:9 is why we
did separation of powers now others had
talked about separation powers
Montesquieu in France and the spirit of
laws nobody had done separation of
powers the way we did until America and
John Adams said we got that out of
Jeremiah 17:9 and by the way Jeremiah
17:9 says the heart is desperately
wicked who can know it
how'd he get separation powers and their
thing is look human tendency is to be
bad hearted unless you have a religious
influence to make you better
and so they said that's the history of
mankind I mean you have three branches
of government Great Britain but when the
king is bad the judiciary is bad and the
parliaments bad based on what we see
that the hearts wicked maybe we can
create a system where that all three
hearts won't be wicked at the same time
maybe judiciary goes bad we can have the
President Congress stop that and so that
bad heart principle that without God's
influence you
you do the wrong things that's what
really drove them to say let's put power
really distinguish and checks and
balances and so we're really the first
government do that but they found it in
biblical reasoning when you get into
oaths and you talk about the oath of
five both clauses in the Constitution
Rufus King signer of the Constitution
talked about how that our oath system
came out of the Bible there you go how
well you start in Genesis where God says
Abraham I swore an oath to use of God
swears an oath then God says I swore an
oath by my right hand and then you go
through and you find four things that we
do in the oath of day matter of fact
we're told Deuteronomy swear oaths in
his name which is why we say so help me
God so everything we do in the oath
founding father Rufus King said we did
the oaths the way we do in America
because what the Bible teaches and so
what we found was it's not just
philosophical part of the culture we
find them saying this Bible verse for
example a guy named James Kent who's
called a father of American
jurisprudence
he said when we created our judicial
system here he's one of the two guys
responsible for our judicial system
he said we set it up with that we have
Circuit Court judges US Supreme Court
today they back in that day they got on
a horse and they actually all rode a
circuit today they're over the ninth
circuit official whatever but James Kent
said we got that out of First Samuel 7
where this says Samuel judged Israel and
he rode the circuit from Gilgal to miss
but the judges were going out among the
people and traveling and that's why they
sort of a circuit court that would
travel so when I found all of those
verses that are specific they're not
just generic tone you know tone verses
these are specific applications they got
me really intrigued but then I think
what really may be the best answer your
question is this book is called the
origins of American constitutionalism
this is done by professors at University
of Houston Poli Sci professors as
published by LSU press and these guys
said you know when you look at the
American documents we're different from
every other nation we have ideas that
our nation's never implemented where our
founders get those ideas and they said
we think that if we go back and read
what they wrote and see who they quoted
we'll know but they got their ideas so
they collected 15,000 represented
varieties out of the founding era they
went through all 15,000 they found 3154
direct quotes it took them ten years to
document every quote back to its
original source at the end of ten years
I said we now know where the founders
got their ideas so the number one most
cited individual and when you've got six
thousand years of writings and you've
got tens of thousands of nations of
coming on you got a lot of people you
can choose from they said the number one
most cited individual was Charles
Montesquieu Baron de Montesquieu out of
France the spirit of the law seventeen
58.3% that's a lot for one guy when you
got thousands of guys to choose from
number two was William Blackstone his
4-volume commentary on the the laws
commentary on the laws
that was number two a 7.9% number three
was john locke at 2.9% particularly this
book my life the two treatises of
government those were the type sighted
individuals but what they found that was
really kind of shocking was the single
most cited source in the American
Founding was the Bible thirty-four
percent as four times more than Locke
for twelve times more than Locke four
times more than Montesquieu four times
more than blacks in the Bible and then
they said which Bible verses were quoted
most often which books and Deuteronomy
was the number one most quoted book were
that Israel isn't building it's nation
Moses is setting up the nation and then
Isaiah was next misquoted and so I mean
even the secular academics have
documented that the Bible was the
primary source in the ideas that shaped
the American Founding so it's not like
it's in the atmosphere notes and the
culture these guys really did think
according to specific Bible verses they
applied them and so between that and the
founders Bible it's pretty compelling
that it was just not the atmosphere of
the culture it was the thinking that
went behind it so another question that
I've asked a lot specifically in this
context is great so the Bible is
instrumental in the American Founding
the Bible is also used for nefarious
purposes people quoting the Bible in
order to justify slavery for centuries
so how do you answer the the accusation
effectively the Bible can be used for
any variety of reasons and some of those
reasons have been quite awful over time
the way I answer is with the concept of
original intent because when you look at
original intent when you take a clause
out of the Constitution you can make it
say something that was never designed to
say for example we say federal judges
have lifetime appointments well the guys
who wrote the Constitution says we
definitely don't want lifetime
appointments for judges that crusade
started in 1765 with Sam Adams who said
the two biggest problems we got rid of
judges is they have lifetime
appointments are not accountable if we
ever get to do a government will never
have lifetime appointments so in the
Constitution actually says good behavior
judges conserve from the Jewish and good
behavior what's good behavior look at
the first six judges they took off the
court in their lifetime you took judges
off the court one guy cussed in the
courtroom they said that's bad behavior
for a federal judge you're gone you know
so there were no lifetime appointments
now we take that clause to say you have
lifetime appointments that's not
original intent well you can take Bible
verses and make them look like they're
pro-slavery but when you read the whole
context of the Bible
it's a Liberty book it's all about
Liberty it's all about self-control it's
all about how you treat others you treat
others the way you want to be treated
you want to be a slave well then don't
make slaves so there will always be
occasions and that that's part of the
nature of man again that's why we had
checks and balances because man's heart
when you are trying to make your ends
justify your means you'll find things
that'll say things that yeah I can take
a Bible verse here there but when you
know the whole scripture and put it all
together it's hard to do that but
there's no question that and this is the
story of human nature you know there's
good people there's bad people even good
people can do bad things like David's
one of the heroes of the Bible my gosh
he's the worst father ever can't raise
his kids and then what it does of the
Sheba and murders Uriah but overall he
did really good things but he had bad
episodes so you in that period time you
can justify a lot and look for verses to
justify so for me it all goes back to
original intent the Bible is a Liberty
book and it's the abolitionists who
finally prevailed and abolitionists were
large
the most religiously dedicated people
were to be the Quakers or the
Congregationalists you know founding
fathers like Benjamin Rush who is found
in the first abolitionist Society
presbyterian those guys that were really
Bible oriented with a the loudest
advocates for anti-slavery and for
freedom yes you have
southern preachers who tried to make
their point even have some Jewish
writers try to make that point
but overall the religious community is
really over here and so even today
you'll have you know little schism sort
of shoot off religious people trying to
make a point and everybody has says wait
a minute that's not what the whole book
says when you take the whole book and I
think that's what you have to do with
that because there's gonna be a
religious people there's some really bad
stuff
but overall religious people have done
much more good than they'd ever done bad
and that's why you have to look at the
good the bad and the ugly and judge the
whole thing but the big picture only
look at your America stands right now
obviously we had deep religious roots
we've seen a lot of those roots really a
relative lot less very few people have
even a baseline familiarity with the
Bible our educational system not only
doesn't teach the Bible but it's
specifically prevented from doing so
so do you haven't what what's your hope
for sort of the future of the country
given the lack of both founding literacy
and biblical literacy that that's
prevailing I'm very active in government
and politics we have a very large
network of legislators that were over I
work in public policy all the time again
been involved in Supreme Court cases
none of that is an excuse for why
individual people don't study the
Scriptures and apply and live with
themselves and teach it to their friends
and neighbors I don't need the
government doing that now that I would
like the government to reinforce what
works and religious morality does work
it'd be nice that they were not enemies
uh but if they were at least allies and
friends and and so even when you look at
recent decisions like the Bladensburg
decision which is where the Supreme
Court said hey it's okay to have that
War Memorial and shape of cross and
Maryland suddenly they're not being
hostile to they're at least
accommodating people's own religious
expressions and so you're in that
situation but that doesn't change the
fact that right now speaking for
Christians only 14 percent of Christians
read the Bible on a daily basis
that's not a government's fault that's
people's fault and but I can't look at
the government and say you know the 1980
Supreme Court case called stone V Graham
and I actually it was about the 10
commandments in Kentucky classrooms I
actually have the copy of the Ten
Commandments that led to that Supreme
Court case it's very intriguing because
in the schools in Kentucky as you would
walk through the school's hallways there
were many pictures hanging on the walls
a picture of George Washington and tape
liner in Cape Hatteras Lighthouse and
horse running through a pasture and but
one of the pictures was a copy of the
Ten Commandments just just hanging there
and it wasn't part of the classroom
wasn't part of the curriculum but the
question was asked what if a student
sees the ten commandments what if they
turn aside and go over there and read
them and this is the question is it
constitutional for a student to
voluntarily read a copy of the Ten
Commandments of school the Supreme Court
came back said absolutely not and to
quote the court that said if a student
were to see the Ten Commandments they
might be induced to read them if they
were read them they might venerate
respect and obey them and that would be
unconstitutional oh yeah things like
don't still and don't kill and don't
purge yourself so legally we can't even
put in front of kids what is hanging in
more than 50 locations in the Supreme
Court your Supreme Court has more than
52 pictures of the Ten Commandments in
it some are in stone some are on the
wall that separates the Supreme Court
bench that justices from the Supreme
Court attorneys there's latticework
their bronze latticework Ten
Commandments on every medallion cross so
you're not letting kids see the basis of
our legal code it's easier to find the
Ten Commandments in a government
building it was in a government building
than a place of worship and now you
can't even do that
so I mean if the government were at
least not hostile it would be helpful
but now they're saying you can't even
let kids know if the Ten Commandments
are thanked how good Chicago would be if
they at least knew the Ten Commandments
to stop killing each other at the rate
of one every eight hours or whatever it
is you know things like don't steal and
don't get those are good wholesome
things so I can look and say I think the
government's had a role in creating an
environment it's very hostile to
religion
we have facilitated what legally we call
the dissenters
Vito if somebody objects to everybody
else sharing their faith we're gonna
make everybody else stops so this guy
want to inject nonsense
you don't let one person Vito everyone
else and so that started and changed
with the new justices new courts we're
starting to win some things we haven't
won in 5060 years
we're seeing a turn but that still will
never excuse why individuals don't go
back and study the Scriptures themselves
learn the teachings live those teachings
become benevolent become good citizens
become moral citizens become good
neighbors help others the government
doesn't do that we can but the
government can reinforce that so second
I want to ask you one final question
okay I'm gonna ask you you brought some
of the artifacts with you today I wanna
ask what are your actual favorite
artifacts that wall Builders has if you
want to hear David Barton's answer you
have to be a daily wire subscriber to
subscribe head on over to daily wire
click subscribe you can hear the end of
our conversation over there Dave Barton
wall builders thank you so much for
stopping by and it's wonderful to hear
the history really appreciate it thanks
Ben appreciate you bro
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike kameena
hair and makeup is by Jessica L Vera
title graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20